Let’s focus on the introduction now. The first
sentence is one of the most important because,
it is the first thing people read.
So, you have to work it and work it
until it is perfect and powerful, just
as the title. Then in the introduction,
make sure that you answer what we call the MRCI
Framework. “M” stands for motivation. What is
the motivation of your topic? Do you explain why
there is a real gap in the literature, but also
why your research question is an interesting one,
a relevant one, an important one? You could also
explain why your research is necessary, but why
no one has done it before. “R” is for results.
What are your findings? That's the part where
you answer the research question. “C” is for
contributions. So how do these results contribute
to the ongoing research or previous literature?
Contributions can be theoretical. They can also be
empirical, when you bring up new data or highlight
new phenomena. And they can be methodological, if
you design a new method that is better than others
or complementary to others. And, finally, “I”
is for implications. What are the implications
of your work for future research? MRCI should
be your guide when writing the introduction,
and the abstract too, since the abstract is
actually just a short version of the introduction.
Next , et's take a look at the literature review.
Keep in mind that most literature reviews are at
best very confusing, at worst downright boring.
So, when you write it, here are some tips to
make a good literature review. First of all,
while you need to have read everything, you
should not put it all down in that section.
Just write what is significant, highly relevant,
and helpful to get to the research problem.
Always make sure that you have a purpose.
You're not just listing references, but you're
conducting an argumentation and demonstration
that's leading you somewhere - to the gap.
To help with that, a good organization, a
proper outline of the review, are essential.
The literature review is a delicate exercise
in finding the right balance between extremes,
for getting references, or being too exhaustive.
Not being critical enough or being too critical.
Not showing enough respect
or showing way too much.
Going back to ancient civilization times or
rejecting anything that's older than five years.
Let's keep in mind that the literature
review is also a political act.
By choosing whom you are quoting, you are
choosing side in the research community.
So, treat carefully and make sure
you're not omitting any key reference.